-Welcome back to the show, Zoe.
-Thank you.
-Who can be hotter
than you right now?
We have things I got
to talk to you about.
So many things.
I'm so happy for you.
-Aww, thanks.
-But you're busy, busy, busy.
-I'm a busy bee.
-Yeah.
"Beau Is Afraid"
is out tomorrow.
This is -- Yeah,
already everyone...
[ Cheers and applause ]
The poster came out online,
and it went viral
just from the poster.
-Yeah. It's insane.
-It's Ari Aster?
-Ari Aster --
I think, one of the great
filmmakers of our time.
You know, "Hereditary,"
"Midsommar."
Now, this is his, like,
epic dark comedy.
-What is it about?
-He describes it
as a Jewish "Lord of the Rings."
[ Laughter ]
Which people have also
described me as.
[ Laughter ]
Which is strange.
It's like -- It's
a three-hour-long
nightmare comedy.
Am I selling it well?
-Yeah, so far.
[ Laughter ]
-And it stars Joaquin Phoenix.
-Yes.
-I play
Joaquin Phoenix' mother.
So I guess I'm in
that stage of my career.
[ Laughter ]
I play her young.
-Okay, good. That makes sense.
-I play a young Patti LuPone,
which is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-That's pressure there.
Did you guys get together
and try to act like...
-Yeah, I had to --
I had to study Patti,
which is like, you know,
any -- any actor's dream.
She's like --
Yeah, she's amazing.
-Phenomenal.
-She's so -- so singular.
She does, like, a lot of really
intense mouth -- mouth acting,
which I had to --
it's almost like Elvis.
Like, there's a lot of,
like, um, like...
-She does do that.
-There's, like, a snarl.
And then she -- and she sort of
talks in the back of her mouth
and...
-That's so Patti LuPone.
-It's not -- It's not great.
-That's a fantastic one.
-It's like she's, um...
-I've never seen anyone do that.
-She's almost, um, chewing,
you know.
-Wow. That is
an amazing impression.
I've never seen anyone
do that before.
-[ Laughs ]
-That is so Patti LuPone.
I love that.
-Thank you.
-A little Elvis.
-It's a little Elvis.
Yeah, I'm a little rusty, but --
But, no, we had so much fun.
-You have that,
but then also then
talk to me about "Slip."
-Oh, man. Well, it's my baby.
-You wrote this,
you directed this,
you're in this.
I mean, wow, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks.
-It's on the Roku Channel.
-Yes.
-Tomorrow. It's called "Slip."
How did you get into it?
What is it about?
What do we have things...
Because it's a story I can't
really explain to people.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Only you could come up with
something like this.
-It follows a character named
Mae, played by yours truly.
And when we meet her,
she's feeling sort of stuck
in her marriage, restless.
And one night, she ends up
cheating on her husband
and then wakes up
the next morning to discover
that she's now married
to the guy
she cheated
on her husband with.
And over the course
of the season,
she realizes
that through orgasm,
she's being transported
into a multiverse.
So, just...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Whoa.
-Yeah.
-W-Wow.
So, how do you think
of an idea like this?
How does the idea --
Can you walk me...
-I'll walk you through it,
Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
Well, um, I'm, like,
the type of person,
like anyone I meet
who I'm even
just moderately attracted to,
I, like, flash-forward
to just a whole-ass life with.
Do you know what I mean?
You know what I mean?
[ Laughing ]
-Do you see someone, you go,
"Hey, I see in the future"?
-Yes, like, you know,
like, when you and I
first met, years ago,
you know, I was like --
You just said hello.
I -- Yeah, I saw --
I saw a life and, um...
[ Laughter ]
Well, [Chuckles], and
it's a "Sliding Doors" thing.
You know, like, I did -- I saw
a wholesome life,
sort of maybe --
maybe like a Wyoming.
Maybe we're running
an organic dairy farm.
I, like...
-Me and you?
-We're out of the business?
Yeah.
We're agriculturally-minded
people.
We have no children.
That's what I'm talking about.
Me and you, Jimmy. Yeah.
Like, no kids,
but, you know, cows and...
[ Laughter ]
-We started
a dairy farm together?
-Yeah. Organic, though.
And that, I think --
And, like,
that's always, like...
I'm obsessed with,
like, the what-ifs.
Do you know what I mean?
Like the "Sliding Doors."
Like, you and I could be here,
you know, you doing
whatever this is,
and me doing...
[ Laughter ]
-The job.
-It's a job, it's a job.
Yeah, it's a job.
-Yeah.
-And -- And me doing what I do.
And -- Or, you know,
we could have just been just...
-Yeah, yeah, we could have
been farmers, yeah.
-Is that how you do it?
Is that how you do it?
-Yes, of course.
-I've never milked a cow.
-No, that's exactly right.
Yeah, it's good.
-I'm going to stop doing that.
-Yeah, please, yeah.
You're this close
to being a meme.
[ Laughter ]
Last time you were on the show,
we talked about your love
for Timothée Chalamet,
and we both share
our love for Timothée Chalamet.
-Yeah, it's slightly different.
-A little different.
I picture Timothée and I
as dairy farmers in the future,
but I couldn't help
but mention --
I couldn't help but notice
that in the first episode,
you mentioned Timothée Chalamet,
and I was going to
ask you about that.
I think he might be in the first
two episodes,
you talked about him.
-Yeah, he's sort of
constantly mentioned throughout.
And it's -- I mean,
look, it's not great.
Like I -- you know,
in my last movie, "How It Ends,"
Olivia Wilde and I
were in a scene
in which she told me
that in the afterlife,
my character would be,
you know, shtupping Chalamet.
And now, in this,
I literally am, like,
invoking his name during climax.
It's like -- It's a problem.
Like, I --
-Yeah.
-It's troubling.
It should be troubling for him.
I'm sure it's troubling
to his team and loved ones,
friends and family.
It's troubling to me.
-It is, yeah.
Have you ever met
Timothée Chalamet?
-Um, well, yes, I have.
[ Laughter ]
-Does he know that you have
a little obsession?
-I think he's aware. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He -- Last time I saw him,
it was at
the Venice Film Festival.
And "How It Ends" had come out.
So he was also aware,
um, of that scene.
And I was, like, standing
across the room from him.
And when he noticed me,
I saw his face sort of fall.
[ Laughter ]
-He was bummed out?
-No, it was -- It was somewhere
between, like, excitement
and sheer terror.
[ Laughter ]
But then we had
a mutual friend,
and she, like,
sort of brought me over.
But before she could
even introduce me,
he was like, "Oh, snap."
Like, he was -- Like, he knew.
Was that a good Chalamet?
-It was a, uh...
-"Snap."
And then - And then...
-That was another
good impression.
-Thank you.
And then he, like, hugged me
and then he sort of
took me in
and was like,
"I thought you were taller."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, a classic Timo neg,
you know?
Like -- But that's sort of
the way to my heart,
you know, is
to just foster insecurity
on...
[ Laughter ]
-But it's interesting
that he knows you
and knows and thought
about your height.
-Well, that is really
the thing is, like,
at first, I was like,
you know, "Ouch."
But then later, I was like,
"Yeah, he thought
about my height," like...
[ Laughter ]
-Timothée Chalamet
goes to bed at night
thinking about
how tall Zoe Lister-Jones is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Congrats on the series.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Zoe Lister-Jones
in "Slip."
Take a look at this.
-Sleeping to find meaning,
and waking to lose it.
And all you want to do is sleep,
to dream of something more.
More.
Just...
-♪ Dream, baby, dream, baby,
dream, baby, dream, baby ♪
-...more.
-Yeah, um, I was just asking
how you're doing
as, like, more of a courtesy.
-Oh. Right. Yeah.
-I mean, you do genuinely
sound [Bleep]-up.
-Thank you. Thanks.
-But I'm literally 24.
-Wow. That's a whole life ahead.
Exciting.
-Yeah, "I wasn't really asking."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Zoe Lister-Jones, everybody!
All episodes of "Slip" are
available tomorrow
on the Roku Channel.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around.